My last blood work was done in the middle of March, I believe that you recommended blood
work every three months and a little past that I'm afraid of.
What exactly you'd recommend I have checked this time.
Last lab continued to show slightly lower cholesterol, but still in the high range.
Do I need to recheck that?
We're not really doing a lot for your cholesterol issue or concentrate on your cancer, but certainly
it doesn't cost really anymore to get that rechecked, so getting a lipid panel would
be a smart thing to do.
Nothing seems to bring that down significantly, because we're not really trying to bring
that down.
On a side note, I could easily feel the tumor in my right breast that male wanted biopsy,
not sure if it's bigger, certainly it's not smaller though.
I'm thinking that tumor tests would, uh, uh, but which ones.
So we have a female tumor panel, that would be the one to do the female tumor marker panel.
Is there anything else in particular?
Certainly a CVC and certainly a complete metabolic panel.
Cheeks swab?
Yes, but that's wait until after the blood test.
Blood pressure continues to run high anywhere from 171 to over 74.
The lowest has been 127 over 65, yeah, that's where we wanted to stay, let's get it to
stay there, I have not had, uh, wellness physical in going on two years because they will put
me on blood pressure medication, don't want to do that, um, uh, they also push for tests
like mammograms, they don't want to do bone density, I don't want to do, um, so, yeah, let's
just get that blood work done, um, it's, if you do our, um, complete wellness panel, that
also has thyroid test, uh, that's always good to look at that too.